Victoria is in Los Angeles hi Victoria
how are you hi Dave I'm fine thanks
sure sorry so I'm calling because on
behalf of my mom she has a life
insurance policy that specific life and
it's a whole life policy that she bought
in 1981 and in 1997 she had some issues
and I've been taking care of her ever
since and going through a bunch of boxes
recently a few years back not really
recently I realized that she had a life
insurance policy that she was getting
she's still getting mail on and they
were premiums and I asked her but it
wasn't she said she thought she stopped
paying on that a long time ago and that
it wasn't valid so I called them and
found out that it was still valid and
what was happening is they were paying
the premium for her and put in a loan
against her policy oh nice okay where
did you stand today so today well last
year what I did today it's that's what I
was gonna call you about it's right now
so last year there was some money in
there they call it a paid up cash value
amount and I don't know how she had that
because they have a wave of accruing
money but you sell alone against the
policies I'm not sure how that works
because I'm not really privy to the
industry like that but there was money
in there and it was several thousand
dollars and she owed like something like
thirty five thousand dollars in a loan
against the policy that was accruing
interest at the rate of 8% and I was
talking to a customer service guy over
there last year before I was paying the
premium and I was trying to hash this
out with him and see if there was
something I could do to stop the the gap
you know stopped the bleeding and he
said well you could take up all your
paid additions paid up additions and pay
off some of the loans and then you'd
have a smaller loan that you have you
could like start making payments upon
the policy and I say you have a 35,000
she has a $35,000 loan against her cash
value you have that and then I we talked
it over and she agreed that we should go
ahead and pay that
okay and so we did and now there's zero
paid up addition so that the total death
benefit before the loan is 25 thousand
what's left in the current cash value
before the loan is seventeen thousand
125 and the current loan debt is
fourteen thousand four sixty to seventy
six the current net death benefit after
the loan is ten thousand five thirty
seven twenty four and if she were to
just cash out today the current cash
value is two thousand six hundred sixty
two dollars and twenty four cents though
are you tired again sorry how are you
not tired of getting screwed yet now I
think has all this crap today right so
what that's I'm calling because they
send me a check for 350 they sent her a
check for 350 208 it looks like they
took the annual dividend of nine twelve
fifty eight and they paid off the annual
premium of five sixty fifty and what's
happened let's kind of talk through this
for a second okay here's why you should
cancel it today and let me make him once
you understand that you'll go oh okay
so basically whole life life insurances
it costs about twenty times more than
term life insurance that extra nineteen
times that you're paying in goes into a
savings account called cash value you
pay extra all loss extra to build up the
savings account okay that's our cash
value and then what did she do she
borrowed against her cash value she
borrowed her own money and paid them
interest this is why I hate these people
[Laughter]
since nineteen eighty why in there it's
it's gone I mean the money's just gone
and so here's what happened here's what
happened not only did she borrow her own
money and pay them eight percent to do
this but then they took the premiums and
borrowed more money against her savings
so that they could keep their stupid
policy in force so she's been borrowing
her own money and paying them interest
too
borrow her own money to buy a life
insurance policy that now nets her ten
thousand dollars after all these years
if she dies or $2,000 net of all these
loans if she catches it in today this is
not going to get anything but worse it's
a it's a trick bag I mean because
there's a loan on it like if there
wasn't a loan on it just leave it alone
[Music]
so canceling that can you roll it over
into a term life you don't need to just
cancel okay just cancel it her health is
bad but you know the money that is tied
up you take the $2,000 and any of our
other assets and start setting that
aside for her burial if God forbid
something happens to her but this this
is just it's gone I mean they have used
her up is what amounts to and that and
you can see that in the math can't you
and then I was thinking now in hindsight
should I have even should have cancelled
it before you did all that paid up
additions out but it's not the other
world there's not there's no taxes on it
because your basis I'm sorry they use
the cash last year and they use the cash
to pay off some of the loan so some of
the loan down they call their her paid
up editions
she got a and I guess a w-9 her 1099
rather and she had to pay taxes on
whatever that amount was and it was like
800 dollars and someone you shouldn't
have there shouldn't have been any taxes
on it because your basis in a whole life
policy is the total of your premiums
paid in and there's no possible way that
her premiums that she's going to get out
of this thing what she has paid into it
never in a million years so we do file
an amended return when you catch this
one out because all you guys go back and
look at all the money she's paid into
this okay and she did not get it all out
and so there is a net there's a net loss
there's not a net gain and she's too old
apparently because I talk to Larry is
Andrea stirred and he she's too
- even by life insurance yeah but she's
I mean she doesn't have any life
insurance now she just got a trick bag
now I mean ten thousand dollars worth
but my god what's your paying for this
$10,000 is asked for not my call yeah
it's not automated return is in the form
that I can get from the tax preparer I'm
sorry say that again
the defile and omitted return an amended
return you do that one you file our
taxes this year go back and amend last
year's filing because the taxes you paid
on that $800 shouldn't have been paid
these guys know you need to get proper
documentation from them on the total of
the premiums paid in that is your
premium I mean that is your basis and
it's way in excess of 22,000 god man
what crooks unbelievable so yeah you got
to get out get away from these people
fast you can